Hi everyone.
Thanks for joining.
Uh,
do they,
as you know,
we have the fantastic and amazing Julio [inaudible] Niggas with us.
[inaudible]
get us started.
I would like to ask you a little bit about your experience being born and raised
in,
in Antiguan,
at,
in growing up,
becoming these fantastic international artist,
grammy winner,
uh,
known all around the world.
Can you tell us a little bit about their experience and what are the key
milestones around that?
Pick your knee.
Okay.
First.
Hi everyone.
It's great to be here and thank you for this whole event.
Um,
well,
uh,
I was born in Long Beach,
actually.
I wasn't born at the corner.
Uh,
I never lived in Long Beach.
I actually,
my parents were moving around California and they,
they're both Mexican,
but they both had their immigration papers and,
but they finally settled into Hawaiian or they just,
they always,
they grew up there and uh,
well practically.
Yeah.
And uh,
they decided that that was the best place to be.
Um,
and I kind of grew up,
I'm a very much a border life,
you know,
I mean,
every time one of our,
one of my brothers or sisters were going to be born,
we'd cross of,
they'd have their kid and go back to you want to.
And um,
problems propels me.
I'm on,
you know,
so,
uh,
Ruben decline on,
but it's very much a border life,
very much.
Um,
bilingual.
I grew up watching American television.
That's how I learned English.
I never studied in the u s uh,
I did,
uh,
do like a junior college when I finished high school because I kind of wanted to
study a career in music.
But in Tukwila the music school wasn't really that developed yet.
So I decided to,
you know,
try to,
start getting my,
um,
what,
what is called [inaudible],
like [inaudible] like the classes.
Yeah,
like the points to get to,
yeah,
the credits.
And uh,
I was in the middle of that when I went to Mexico City to visit and I just kind
of fell in love with the city.
I found.
I was like,
I don't want to,
I don't want to leave this place.
It just completely blew my mind.
I mean,
I'd been in big cities.
I not really that kind of big cities I had been like in,
I dunno,
like Los Angeles or San Francisco,
you know,
but when I got to Mexico City,
it's like part of me completed itself.
I was like always in the Guana thinking about Mexico.
My Dad was so much about Mexico.
We were always talking about Mexico.
But the [inaudible],
uh,
was not,
you know,
it was,
it was a mix.
It wasn't exactly Mexican.
It wasn't exactly us.
So,
um,
when I,
when I saw Mexico City,
I've,
I decided I had to live there,
of course.
And so I went back to the Quanah,
picked up my stuff and just,
I've been there 20 years.
That's the personal side.
Um,
musically I was,
uh,
I started,
studying classical piano when I was eight.
My parents thought it would be good for us to not watch too much TV.
So,
you know,
they had a studying piano and,
uh,
all kinds of lessons,
belay,
belay at painting,
whatever,
whatever came to their minds.
And I was terrible at everything.
And for some reason I came out being really good at music.
So,
uh,
so,
you know,
I,
I started studying,
um,
I studied classical,
like what's he say,
blessing to be the wireless particular classes,
uh,
for like eight years.
And then,
um,
I started playing in bands when I was in high school.
A friend of mine invited me to a band as a keyboard player.
And,
uh,
I discovered,
you know,
improvisation and singing and just kind of,
it was,
it was a completely different path.
And the important thing for me there was that I'd discovered songwriting.
And that was basically what made me shift my path completely.
And I started doing songwriting after that.
And also at the same time,
I started doing music,
music for theater.
So it was instrumental and it was also songs.
And so I kept on developing that.
And then,
um,
by the time I was,
what,
like 22,
that's when I went to Mexico City.
Um,
I was still kind of searching for what I wanted.
I kept on putting bands together because I always thought I had to be in a band
and it didn't,
it never worked out.
I always like did a lot of writing with a few different people.
And when I,
when I got to Mexico City,
I actually put posters up trying to get a band together that way.
We did it before,
like Internet,
you modern people would know about that.
I did like
prison record stores and stuff like that and I put a band together and it didn't
work out either.
But in one of those shows I met,
uh,
two,
three of the guys from [inaudible],
which was really important for me because I started going out with one of them
[inaudible]
so it was fairly important for him because,
um,
she's someone who really influenced me in saying like,
why do you want to keep putting bands together?
It just do your thing.
You have these great songs I can in your drawer,
but you keep putting bands together and making other songs and it's just like,
and I always dreamed of getting an accordion.
It was always like my dream.
And he was like,
he pushed me into like,
just get you a cornea,
need a drum machine and leave me alone.
So
I got,
so I started doing shows by myself with just piano accordion and a drum machine.
I started opening for a bunch of bands in Mexico City and I actually did a,
like an eight track demo,
which was a big deal then.
And uh,
a lot of people started like,
uh,
giving it to friends and it kind of became a walk.
I walk,
I like,
oh,
there's this girl,
she plays accordion and she's sayings.
And um,
and that way I started,
I started playing with a few musician friends and uh,
woo in those shows.
I Dunno,
things started happening really quickly.
All of a sudden,
nothing happened for ages for a long time.
But then all of a sudden people started showing up to my shows and record labels
started showing up to Michelle,
the people from record labels,
like three different record labels were interested.
They,
they'd heard the demo and um,
and you know,
one thing,
do another and here we are now.
Okay.
I got signed.
I,
I uh,
yeah,
and that was a long time ago.
That was almost what,
like a long time ago.
It must've been like an I got signed I think in like [inaudible] 95,
96 or something.
And then after that it's been like,
I mean I put two albums that were not so well known outside of Mexico,
which were our key in one Bento and,
but I was touring a lot anyway and,
but I really want it to tour more.
I felt like I was just kind of touring around Mexico,
but it was really hard for me to leave.
And also I had this sort of revelation between my second and my third album.
I had like a year where I had this sort of crisis,
like what kind of songwriter do I really want to be?
Do I really want to be this,
um,
very experimental sort of song writer?
Do I want to or do I want to express and communicate more with people?
And that was like a year of,
you know,
thinking and writing and having this super crisis and what do I want?
Because uh,
my second album had been a really critically acclaimed but very difficult album
in every sense.
Recording.
It was difficult.
I'm touring with,
with difficult,
it was just like really?
And I was like,
maybe I'm taking the wrong sort of path.
Maybe I'd want something else as a song writer,
I wanted to do songs that were more con that connected differently with people,
you know,
not like one day I remember being on the stage and sort of playing my super
complicated and wonderful songs and somebody and I just felt like people would
just kind of staring at me like,
who is this Marcia?
And I just kind of wanted,
you know,
I want to connect.
That's what music is about.
Communication.
And that's what I wanted.
And so that took a lot of,
you know,
self analyzing and I never believed in analysis.
So actually I had did my own self analysis and that's how I,
you know,
I started writing c,
which was my third album and that was kind of a breakthrough.
I think that was the first time that I actually,
uh,
went,
into the radio that I started actually sounding in the radio that people were
like,
uh,
people thought,
a lot of people think that's my first album,
but that's my third album.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
after that,
a lot of things have happened,
but that was our,
that was already a while ago.
That was in 2003.
So it's been a while
perfect on it.
And I think you're doing a fantastic job just connecting with people with your
music.
You can feel it when you,
when
you hear your songs.
Um,
and one of the themes that I'm hearing in,
in,
in your career is this sense of,
of,
um,
just being persistent,
right?
Like,
even if things were not happening at the beginning,
even if,
if there was a dry fail,
try again.
Um,
and then if the,
the it actually happened,
I mean,
it became a very big success for you.
Can you tell us a little bit about how,
how you were thinking about this process of I need to get up,
try again,
try something different.
Really find myself going to even self analysis.
Amen.
Well,
then what happens,
I think is that I really enjoy the process of things.
I don't believe in,
you know,
this is what I have to be by this time.
This is what I really love,
the process of how you become who you are in,
in,
in every sense.
Even now that I've already put out like seven or eight albums that I've been
touring forever,
that I,
I enjoy what I do also because I enjoy every bit of what I do,
every different part,
what it means to do what I do,
which is every time I finished the tour,
I dedicate myself like four months to just writing.
I didn't do anything else.
Um,
and then when I'm touring,
I just really enjoy the tour itself.
I enjoy the shows.
I enjoy like that connection with people.
Um,
I think the important thing is that it's not only the thing about,
uh,
how you get to where you want to get to,
but it's just like the whole,
the whole learning experience in the whole learning process,
which I think is really a constant thing.
It's not something that starts and ends when you get what you want.
You are always sort of learning from what you,
even when you get what you want me to start learning,
you still wonder if that was the right thing and you,
you know,
you keep going.
And I think what I really like to do is just ask questions all the time about
what I really want.
And I'm very curious about,
um,
about songwriting and I'm still curious about it.
I've gotten about getting into the studio and see what happens.
And it's not just,
you know,
oh no,
it's like a sort of like a routine thing.
I still feel the same,
uh,
nerves,
the same,
um,
intensity of,
of,
of trying a new song and just putting it together and then arranging it and then
going to the studio and in producing it,
it's just all like,
uh,
it's still sort of new in a way for me.
You know,
if when I started actually doing it,
I don't feel like I know the steps in.
I really prefer it that way because,
um,
I dunno.
I always think that it's better to forget what you learn and keep learning.
Even if you have to relearn.
It's actually better.
It's a better feeling.
And I've always let my,
let myself be guided by my intuition more than what I know,
you know,
more than what I've learned.
It's more like what is my,
you know,
sort of instinct telling me to do at this moment.
I know and that's something I ask myself all the time.
That sounds great then I think it's great.
And as part of all this on just redefining yourself,
just keep asking questions.
It sounds that along the way there were also some opportunities and some
challenges that you might have faced being Mexican American and then just trying
to break into an international market.
Can you tell us how you were thinking about that process of,
of,
oh wait,
maybe this is becoming something big or do I want to go that way?
Do I want to hold the date?
How do I want to,
to,
to think about myself in the future if there is no,
not a lot of,
I mean,
a point a and I want to get to point B.
It's more a self reflection along the way.
How did this process happen to you?
Well,
um,
when,
when I think about the whole,
uh,
my career in the sense of maybe when I found myself,
people ask me a lot of why,
why I don't sing in English,
for example.
I think the language has been,
um,
something that's been very important for me because,
even though I grew up in a,
in a border city,
even if I'm bilingual,
I'm writing in Spanish to me is much more natural.
I mean I've never tried running an English really.
And it's not something that I know that now it's,
I see a lot of artists who find it more natural.
And I think it's great,
especially when you're live in the u s who speak Spanish,
you speak English.
But my mom always spoke to me in Spanish,
you know,
and,
and my boyfriends,
everything,
every,
my emotional life has been constructed in a telecon,
Sweden.
Hispaniola so for me,
writing has to do with my own language.
So at one point,
yeah,
they started asking me like,
are you going to do like a crossover?
And I'm like,
I would like people to cross over to my side language,
you know,
this is what I celebrate when I write a song.
And I think part of the,
the search for me,
because I'm influenced by a lot of books in English and obviously musicians in
English and the English language is very present in my life at least.
And,
but when I sit down to write,
it's more connected with my emotions or Spanish is much more connected to my
emotions.
So,
so I find it a lot more natural.
I think that's the only place where I found like,
uh,
at one point,
um,
when I put out my fourth album with money style,
it's just started getting super big and it started like,
yeah,
we're going to,
it's starting to grow louder.
We want to do more of Europe,
we want to go to Germany and we want to do,
go to Italy.
And when it started just kind of like growing a lot.
And at one point,
um,
you know,
things started coming up like,
oh,
you know,
to sound in Germany,
you have to do this,
you have to have somebody else to,
an arrangement for the song and you have to do this.
If you want to,
you know,
sound in Portugal,
you have to do a duet with this artists you've never even met.
You don't even know and you have to do it.
And I was like,
you know what?
Let's just let it flow.
You know,
let's let it be natural.
If it's not going to happen,
it's not going to happen.
Maybe I needed a,
an extra bit of ambition that I didn't really have because I,
I kind of enjoyed when I was doing and I was like,
if people want to listen to what I do the way I do it,
it's,
but I don't want to like sort of invent something that I'm not to sound in
radio.
And you know,
somewhere else we rental,
he did go to Germany to do a tour and it was great and we eventually did go to
Italy to determine,
you know,
it eventually things happened,
but it didn't happen like at the point where everybody wanted them to happen.
Like,
yes,
now is the moment where Europe is going to be taken,
you know?
Huh.
No,
I mean,
let's just kind of let it flow and let's,
you know,
I don't know.
I just don't think that,
that I,
I really needed that.
And I don't call myself not ambitious because I am,
I mean the fact that I'm doing music and then I'm still doing it now means that,
I guess I do.
And I think we all need a little bit of ambition in our lives.
You know,
to do anything,
anything at all.
It's like,
you know,
you wake up in the morning and you say,
I want to get up and do something that requires some sort of ambition,
you know,
and sort of growing and learning and all that.
But at one point you wonder like how far you want to take things.
And I was like,
this is all that I am.
I can't be more than I am.
I can invent somebody that I'm not.
So,
you know,
this is as far as I'll go.
And then we'll see what happens.
Of course.
And
I think the,
the organic growth that you were mentioning that without making a lot of
sacrifices actually makes your music and you as,
as an artist,
very authentic brewery.
You know,
and just taking a quick look around the group here,
I know the majority of the posterior cord Latinos,
Lamar Habla Espanol problem and Oh,
but I even see,
for instance,
people from Germany here in the auditorium,
which is really,
really fantastic.
Um,
and as part of,
of all these cultural interaction.
Yeah.
It's funny that you mentioned Germany,
um,
as fourth of these,
these,
um,
multicultural interaction of understanding what specific to every market,
what needs to be adjusted so that you can be successful as Latinos,
many of us know the,
the,
the big challenges that we see just going international,
being successful.
They,
they sometimes the stereotypes and all that.
And I think we're,
we're all very conscious about that.
Um,
so rather than asking you about those challenges,
how allowed to ask you about the opportunities,
what do you see as an opportunity for,
for being Latino yet?
For instance,
I seen your career,
there were a lot of partnerships along the way.
People who also being Latinos,
they,
they help you along the way.
They,
maybe they,
they duck you,
hey,
we should do this or we should do,
I dunno for him up and simple like that.
Can you talk a little bit more about that positive side that you see us
something very special and unique of the Latino culture?
Um,
yeah,
the family.
I think that,
uh,
Latin America has,
we're all connected not only through our language but also culturally.
We are all,
we're all have this,
we're all very complex countries.
You know,
we've,
we've had very complex histories and we're racially very diverse in,
in,
in a different sense than how it is here in the United States.
You know what I mean?
In Mexico.
[inaudible] in a lot of the countries,
most countries in Latin America,
we're very much a mixed cultures.
And,
and we grew up with a sort of a richness and also with a sort of,
uh,
with all this like great history and terrible history of conquest.
But also that is what made us,
we are right.
So,
uh,
I do think that we have that in common and culturally that makes us very,
I think each one has their own identity and very proud identities.
And I mean for,
for example,
in Mexico,
I think that we are,
I mean,
I think Mexico is just like a brilliant and amazing and surprising country even
with all our problems.
And I speak of Mexico in particular because I don't like to speak so much,
just so generally at the same time,
we're very corrupt and we have a lot of problems and allowed.
That's where a lot of people just have the need to leave and try out,
you know,
like tried to make things happen for them in a different place.
Um,
because there's also like a lot of poverty,
a lot of,
uh,
violence.
There's many things that make,
uh,
our,
our country are very,
um,
mixed place.
Um,
it's beautiful.
It's,
uh,
I haven't been able to leave and I don't want to leave.
The other day somebody was asking me,
why don't you come here?
You know,
like to the u s it's just,
you have,
because I have a two nationalities,
right?
So it's like,
you know,
but,
uh,
I'm in love with that city.
I want to educate my daughter in that country and I want to,
or,
you know,
I want her to be proud of her country,
you know?
And,
and it's a beautiful place.
It's beautiful.
And,
and it's also heartbreaking sometimes to see a lot of the things that are
happening.
And I've written a lot about that in some of my songs and it's always present
because it's sort of like a different,
uh,
pain that you feel maybe in a different,
love that also you feel for that place,
for the people that we are.
And I think that's something that a lot of people share in different countries
in Latin America that you have this sort of love and fear and at the same time
hope you know,
all the things coming together and working out for everybody of course.
And being from Mexico City,
I might be slightly biased,
but yeah,
I agree with you.
It's a fantastic city to live in and everybody should go and LBC time.
Um,
but,
but it's also,
there's one thing that you touched on that I think it's,
it's very specific to two Mexican direct sample,
but it also happens or happened in other Latin American countries.
There is these,
these CD,
these countries certainly not perfect.
It's far from it.
We,
we know the,
the,
the huge problems.
But there are in,
in society,
in government,
in,
in every aspect of everyday life.
However,
that doesn't mean you don't love the country.
That doesn't mean you don't absolutely love the cedia.
Unlike returning there,
unlike stablish in your entire life there.
And I think that's what sets many Latin American cultures support.
There is this law,
their seas familiar feeling of everywhere we go.
These cast,
um,
modify the rain away shaped the way you do.
Do the music that what you think about your career and everything,
um,
as compared to any other international artists you might know?
Um,
I'm not sure.
I mean I can't really compare myself with other artists.
I mean I can say,
oh,
I did it like this when they did it like that.
It's uh,
I think everybody is,
um,
everybody's music has to do with their identity in one way or another.
No matter what style you make,
it's personal.
It's always personal.
So it's always about who you are,
where you're from,
what's your,
what's your history like what you like to look at in your own country or another
countries,
you know.
Um,
for me,
making music has to do with my route.
And that's not,
not only in the obvious sense,
which is like folklore and Mexican,
uh,
from Lord.
It's also a in every sense culturally.
Um,
the way that I think has to do with the fact that I'm from Tijuana but I went to
Mexico.
All my decisions have been based on the fact that I am who I am.
And I think that music is made that way.
Everything our art is made that way.
It's personal.
So it,
you're kind of telling your own story and your music and I can use it,
for example,
in a song I'll put in the super Nathaniel accordion,
but I also like to put in like something like a super,
a synthesizer and mix it up.
And because that's the person that I am,
you know,
maybe it sounds kind of schizophrenia when you talk about it conceptually,
but for me it works.
You know,
I don't,
I don't find it to be shot and in the song and it works.
And I think that has to do with the fact that I'm from Tijuana and I grew up
listening to,
I mean my mom would sing dealers and latte on her way to school every morning.
Tracy.
It's kind of funny,
but she did every morning he should do,
could be clear.
So,
you know,
it's not so bad,
it's not so far away from my telling him that I mixed that,
you know,
and an accordion and a really like a melodic sort of idea.
And I find the festivity of the accordion,
uh,
has to do with my character,
you know?
And,
and also the seriousness of a piano or this year is,
is I kind of,
and I think that we're all telling our own stories.
You know what I'm kind of telling my stories in my songs and every story that I
tell in my lyrics are also musically the why did I decide to dress up?
The song has to do with who I am.
So,
yes,
I think that definitely,
um,
Mexico and also us and also the Quanta and also my family and whatever it is
that I'm feeling at that moment.
It has to do with what I'm doing when I'm writing course.
It is the accordion your favorite instrument?
Well,
actually,
um,
we'll keep this a secret,
but my favorite,
my favorite instrument is a piano.
I'm,
I'm actually,
I always say that I'm a,
I'm a,
um,
I'm a [inaudible] and a pianist dressed up as an accordion player because I'm
actually a pianist.
I write in the piano.
Um,
actually when I write songs now,
I used to do it differently but it's always been changing.
But now I sit down at the piano with nothing but my phone.
And I do my,
and I write songs on piano and maybe I'll use a drum machine,
but it's mostly just piano.
And after that I'll start building the song up and sometimes I'll use accordion,
sometimes I won't.
It's more like a for ranging.
I love arranging and also I love to play it in,
in the stage because it's so fun.
You know,
it's like you bring up the accordion is like,
yeah,
it's like bringing up in like a last over something.
It's really fun.
Uh,
it,
it's,
I think that's what the shows are about.
It's about fun and also just kind of making it like all different kinds of
feelings,
you know,
you go and I think definitely the accordion bring sort of like a festive in,
in sort of a common alegria joy,
a joyous feeling for me,
you know?
Perfect.
And don't worry,
we'll keep this a secret.
Okay.
Thanks.
Disregarding the fact that he's,
this is going to be posted in talks at Google and the youtube channel.
Other than that,
it's a secret between you and me,
um,
with,
with this duality that,
that you're talking about and I think it reflects on a lot of the music that you
do right there.
It's the seriousness of the,
of the piano,
but then bringing out the accordion and as you mentioned,
is like bringing the last or two to,
to somebody who plays the seriousness of classic piano music.
Um,
is that how you always see things?
He is that,
do we try to mix all of these different elements?
He what works better in every single case and then just do it.
Is that a conscious process or is it yours?
However it's coming for you.
And what do you feel in the moment?
Well,
we come,
we come back to the,
to the idea that I said before,
it's,
it's intuition.
I keep letting intuition and sort of guide me.
I don't like,
I'm not conceptual in that sense.
It's not like it started writing a song and think this has to be this sort of
song and it has to finish sounding like this.
I never really know.
It's very,
it's very organic.
I started serving,
I always say it's like knitting,
breading,
a song,
you know,
you put the verse and you kind of bring it onto something else and you,
it's sort of like a live process.
You don't really know what's going to happen.
And it happens when I'm writing a song,
I know it also happens when I'm arranging it.
It's sort of a live thing you do.
It's,
and that's,
I think that's the magic of it.
And that's why I keep on doing it because it's so,
um,
it's,
come on,
you don't know what's going to happen,
you know,
and I'm predictable.
So I think that's,
that's what I really like about it.
I don't,
I don't think that after,
I mean I now I know that I can run,
I can sit down and write a song because I used to be like very doubtful.
I'm always,
I was a skeptic in every sense of it took me years to,
to,
you know,
kind of figuring out why people are going to my shows.
It took me years to say,
yeah,
okay,
I put some albums out and I've never really believed the whole thing.
You know?
It's always like,
yeah,
this is who I am.
But it doesn't mean that,
you know,
nothing is going to happen.
And then,
and I'd always say like,
well,
I'm not sure if when I sit down I'm going to actually come up with a song.
But now,
you know,
after this time I know that I am going to come up with a song because I like it
and I'm going to sit there until I do.
And I'm very like,
and also that I'm very disciplined.
I mean when I sit down to write,
it's like,
um,
I do like I do the nine to five.
Excellent.
And that's what I do.
I mean,
I,
I stopped the tour.
I don't,
um,
I don't like trying to write when I'm traveling.
When I'm traveling,
I like to read,
I read all the time.
Um,
but when I,
when I'm writing,
it's like nine to five thing.
I've stopped for lunch.
But I,
and also having a daughter,
it makes me more disciplined in that sense because you used to be,
when I was going to write an album,
I could take like,
you know,
the the day and sort of just read and then go to the piano.
But now I know that I have those hours.
And for her it's also easier to fit,
you know,
to say,
okay,
you're done at this time and we can just hang out.
And,
and for me it's like I can disconnect and just be where I am.
Yeah,
of course.
It's funny that you mentioned that because at least for me,
from an external point of view of Nora musician or a songwriter,
not an artist,
certainly even though I played piano,
but that's about it.
For a lot of people outside these,
the,
these artist environment,
it sounds like it's a matter of inspiration.
Like you're basically walking down life and then inspiration comes and you're
like,
I need a piece of paper and then start writing down.
Uh,
but it turns out that's not the case with you,
that,
that you do the,
the,
the formal IC down and then at some point ideas are going to come.
Is that typical for everybody who,
who grinds songs?
Is that specific to Kalita
how's that?
I think everybody's different too,
right?
I don't know how other people write songs.
Um,
I've never had that miracle.
You know,
that,
that idea that,
you know,
will just come to my head and I have a song in my head,
let me sit down and write it.
No,
I have to,
I have to kind of search for it.
And,
uh,
I like it that way because it's,
um,
at first you're kind of fearful of when you sit down and you see the blank
notebook because also I don't even have lyrics when I sit down.
I don't,
I read everything together.
I maybe I'll have like one line or something and I'll start working with that.
But usually,
um,
it all comes up together.
I mean,
I'll just kind of like,
I started with,
I started with one line and that'll bring me onto the rest of it.
It's,
and so,
um,
I think other people,
I mean,
I'm sure there are people who ride on tour,
people who like to wait for the songs to come,
you know?
But I really,
I liked the fact that I can sit down and,
you know,
find something because also if nothing comes up,
I'll just keep on playing the piano.
And,
which is something that I really enjoy.
It's a different thing.
And also,
uh,
it's like,
I don't like to feel like I'm searching for the song.
I'm just like,
I'm going to play,
let it come,
you know,
and that kind of thing.
So,
uh,
but yeah,
really,
I really,
it's just that I've always been very much in love with the piano and playing the
piano is also kind of therapeutic for me.
I mean it's Kinda sit down and improvise all the time.
I,
I mean,
I do,
I do read notes and I do some exercises to warm up my hands and kind of like,
but,
um,
but also just kind of like to improvise.
Perfect.
And I want to be conscious of the time.
I think we,
we have them,
we might open the floor to,
to a couple of questions from the other cities,
but that's fine with you.
Um,
just a quick question before that.
What's your favorite [inaudible]
I don't have a favorite.
Couldn't get the song.
It's crazy.
Um,
when I finished my album,
I'm serious on that.
You're looking at me like,
oh my gosh,
she's crazy.
No,
I'm,
I'm curious.
Um,
I,
whenever I bet I finished an album that I've,
I mean when I'm writing,
maybe I'll have a favorite,
like for a day or two.
And then I come up with another one,
which is my favorite and then that,
um,
but when I finished an album,
I actually,
when I'm done with the whole writing process in producing it and I'll listen to
it obsessively,
I'll be all day,
like wondering if that's the right way to structure it,
if that's the right way to do it and blah,
blah,
blah.
And when I'm done with it,
it's like,
okay,
I'm done.
That's it.
I never listened to it again.
I might listen to a song when I'm,
I'm trying to,
uh,
to bring it back for a show or,
you know,
and,
but I'm very,
very lazy about listening to my own song.
No answer.
This is like looking into a mirror,
you know,
you're look into a mirror.
Yeah.
You use it,
you know,
you weren't makeup,
whatever.
You comb your hair,
you shave or whatever,
and then that's it.
There's no surprises there.
And for me listening to music has to do with,
wow,
how do they come up with that or oh,
you know,
just being like moved by somebody by their story,
by what's happening to you at that moment.
And that happens to me with other people's music,
not with mine.
It's okay.
Perfectly.
Let's open it up for audience questions.
Um,
um,
I always a thing.
So
yeah,
I always say is,
uh,
before uh,
clean and Mexican.
I am from the corner and I am the same as you.
I was born in the u s but I grew up in,
in Mexico.
And my comment or question is related to that.
Um,
I have the feeling that,
um,
for many of,
or people that come from Latin American countries,
people focus the negative part.
And it's true.
We are not blind to what's going on,
but there's so many things,
positives about every place in this planet that,
that I always find it a little bit sad.
I don't get offended because I know,
but,
but um,
can you share with us something that you really liked from Tijuana?
Like I can tell you that,
that nothing beats a concert in Tijuana.
Like broken espanol in Tijuana is the best thing in the world.
Yeah,
no,
definitely.
I think,
um,
I think the corners is very unique place.
That's,
that's what it has that you don't realize it when you're growing up there,
but how different it is from any other city,
either in the US or in Mexico.
It has nothing to do with also not even with any other border city.
I love border cities and that's something that I,
whenever I'm in a board of surgery,
I feel like I can understand,
you know,
the idea of living between two countries always.
Um,
but I think definitely the one is very special border because it's part of the
California.
Well,
I mean come on and you know,
the,
the coast is beautiful and the food,
the food is definitely amazing.
So yeah,
I would,
I really love having grown up there.
I think,
I don't think I could,
I could possibly choose any other city because also when I got to Mexico City,
people found me to be a bit of a marsh and being no tenure because North tenured
and people from the north of the country,
we're very direct.
We're dislike.
This is what I'm thinking.
And it comes out like that.
And in Mexico City I always,
I had a hard time getting adapted to the way that people are.
They're very,
so they go around,
they don't say what they're thinking and we're all like,
nothing is,
are like,
yeah,
just say it.
You know?
So yeah,
definitely.
I think,
yeah.
And I think that the public in the corner just like crazy and grades and I
always like,
and my family lives there actually,
they're still live between the quantum San Diego.
Part of them live in San Diego,
part of them.
Some of them go to school and the coin and live in Tijuana.
Others work in San Diego and live in coin.
It's kind of like,
you know,
both sides.
Um,
actually this is like way that I would like to 10,
that comment,
which is a friend of mine came with me to decline or one day to visit and she
hadn't been there before and I was like,
you can't do the cornea have to come.
And she came and she didn't bring her passport and I'm like,
you came without your passport.
I mean,
what?
She's like,
I thought we would come to the quantum like,
yeah,
but coming to the white Annise all the crossing to San Diego.
So I'm like,
you're going to,
you're going to get to know like half the city now.
It's like,
you know,
it's sort of like the whole experience kind of goes together with [inaudible],
you know?
So yeah,
that was,
yeah,
it was kind of mad,
but I was like,
sorry,
I didn't explain.
I thought you knew.
Um,
I also,
I'm a big fun and,
uh,
I'm not from Tijuana,
but I live in Santa Anna and I'm from Mexico City.
So I relate to many of the things you said.
Um,
I have two questions.
One is that you said before that you want to educate your,
your child in city.
I would like to know why.
And,
uh,
also,
if you can share some of your favorite music,
if not a favorite Julietta song,
a favorite,
some of your favorites for other artists.
Well,
I,
I think the education part is because I love,
uh,
I love her growing up in Mexico City.
I think it's just a city that has so much.
Um,
we live in Culiacan,
which is a part of the city that I love.
And,
um,
she's very,
uh,
sometimes she asked him why,
why we don't live in the beach,
which is kind of a really a big conflict,
you know,
and she's only five and that kind of look at her like,
what?
But we live in Mexico City.
There's no place better than this,
you know?
And she's like,
no,
there's no dolphins here.
And we do have a bit of,
I'm sure it's going to come up again,
you know,
but I just kind of really,
I liked the school where she's at.
I actually,
she's,
she's studying in a bilingual school,
which I kind of like that because I'm bilingual and I can relate to her being
bilingual.
Um,
although she,
right now,
she,
San Diego,
I've loved English.
She started like,
you know,
I'll,
I'll talk to her in English being all like,
Hey,
let's,
let's practice English.
And she'll be like,
see Mama.
Okay.
But I just,
I dunno,
I dunno how to explain it.
It's this feeling that I love Mexico City and I love Mexican culture in every
sense.
And I like her being bilingual.
And eventually I think we'll probably come to San Diego,
you know?
And we spent a lot of times and they with my parents because they live there.
But,
um,
I just like Mexico City,
you know,
I like the,
I like her being in,
growing up in a big city,
but that's just because I love big cities.
And maybe when she grows up she'll be like,
I want to go to and say no,
I don't know.
I don't know why I grew up in Mexico City.
Like you.
Yes.
Yeah.
And what was the other question?
Oh yeah.
Of course a woof,
don't get me started.
Okay.
No music.
I've been listening a lot to,
there's a band from Argentina who's called the Skyler's explored a Lotis.
It's very beautiful.
Um,
he's a,
he's actually a guy,
not a girl,
but,
um,
he's,
he's kind of,
and the,
it's pretty beautiful.
He's,
he's,
he's pretty amazing.
Um,
there's also,
uh,
I don't know if you know,
having a minute.
She's from Tila and she's beautiful.
Also kept bay also from [inaudible].
I'm from Mexico.
I'm sure everybody knows Carla Morrison,
but I love her and I love her new album and we're,
we're in when she's beautiful and talented.
Um,
who else?
Oh,
there's a band from Mexico called sent out who's,
they're not new,
new,
but I know a lot of people don't know them and I really recommend them,
like,
oh,
why is pretty great.
So those are some bands,
um,
books.
Uh,
what's it's,
is that recently I've been pretty much into the second war,
which is kind of not so,
you know,
but there is one,
I mean,
if anybody's into that and if not,
I really think you should read this book.
It's a,
it's not actually new,
but,
um,
I just barely read it this year and I'm pretty amazed by it.
It's called life and fate by Vasily Grossman.
Um,
he basically,
he was during,
he was in the,
it's,
it's all about the styling row Kamala between Russia,
the Russians and the Germans.
And um,
he was there the whole time.
So it's,
he's sort of like,
they'll just panoramic view of every single different situation that can
possibly,
that was affected by people during the war,
which is pretty amazing and it's beautiful.
And I'm serious.
I was,
that was probably like one of the books that I've read lately that kind of,
it took me a while to get a,
like when I was done with it,
I just had this feeling of loss of not being a,
being done with it.
You know,
it was,
it was no faith.
It'd be that either.
Stino must pretty great.
We have for,
okay.
I think we're out of time on a very tight schedule today because we're going to
do a,
hi,
I'm from Purdue.
I'm very excited to be here.
Uh,
I have been at Google for three weeks,
so when my asked me like,
hello,
like,
and I was like,
I'm going to see,
uh,
you mentioned that you have studied music since you were little backhoe.
How was the process for you to like,
decided that Nielsen was going to be your career?
You know,
like for a lot of us,
like we have very traditional,
like may years and music is a really hard industry in terms of a spool rates.
Right?
Uh,
and before you became famous,
like how do you decide that?
Like if you using know,
if you were,
be able to support yourself the next month,
you know?
Um,
well actually when I,
when I decided that I was going to make music was totally impractical,
I was actually like,
well,
I was 10 years old and I,
and I decided
that that was going to be what,
that was my vocation.
That's what I wanted to do.
I had no idea at that moment.
I thought I wanted to go to conservatory and studied classical music and beer.
I want it to be an orchestra director and later changed completely.
But,
um,
that's when I decided that was totally like,
I ha I had no idea what's going to happen,
what was going to happen with my life and what way it was going to go or
anything.
I just kind of,
I knew it wasn't,
uh,
something like a position.
It was just sort of like something that came from my body,
you know,
like this is what I am.
And that was sort of like a realization about who I was,
about my identity.
And as a personal,
personal thing,
I'm a twin.
So it was very important for me to realize that because being a twin,
you're always always trying to find your identity and who you are and your
individuality.
And I think music helped me being who I am and every sentence.
And I think also that,
you know,
just kind of my sister's a photographer,
which is kind of funny.
She's like visual and I'm like musical,
which is,
we both found who we were and that's how the relationship alive and the,
what was the other question?
Sorry.
Oh No.
Like,
uh,
how did you decide these to be your major?
In terms of your career,
it doesn't like three major.
Well,
also,
that was funny because,
um,
I had no idea what I was going to do.
I mean,
when I was my idea of going to the university,
I,
I want to study ethnomusicology,
which is not at all what I'm doing now.
So I guess it was just like the idea of going to the university and to study
music.
That was like an idea that I had.
Then I went to Mexico City and I started teaching English when I'd never studied
grammar.
It's kind of funny,
but yeah.
Um,
it's not so funny.
Never do that.
But,
um,
I needed,
you know,
I need a job.
My accident was pretty,
you know,
oh,
you're,
you know,
you're practically California.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
just kind of
taught English and you know,
that's what I did for the first year.
And then I,
I did,
uh,
my first musical job was to do music for theater,
for a play.
And so,
uh,
that was my first job.
But yeah,
I,
it was,
it was hard in the beginning because my parents were pretty much like,
oh,
you're leaving to Mexico City.
Great.
I'm not going to help you.
And it was like,
okay,
I'll do this.
I can do this.
I got this.
And Yeah,
the,
the first year was pretty tough,
but yeah.
Um,
and you know,
I have no idea what's going to happen.
I mean,
maybe eventually I could have given up and I kinda said,
and actually at one point I did,
I was about to give up.
I,
I came,
all my family pitched into for a ticket for me to come spend Christmas with
them,
which was kind of sweet except my dad,
of course,
he was still mad,
but,
um,
but I've had this conversation with my mom and I said,
mom,
I don't think I can do this.
I mean,
I'm going to go back.
I don't know how I'm going to pay the rent.
I,
this is like a struggle.
I'm alone.
I don't really know anybody.
This is too much for me.
And my mom was like,
don't come back.
I mean you've had,
every time I say that,
I kind of want to cry.
She's like,
set up [inaudible] they don't come back.
I mean,
I've never told you this,
but my dream in life was to be a singer and I never did it.
And you're doing it.
I'm like,
hmm.
I mean,
I haven't done anything,
but for me that was like
the best person she could have given me and then they pitched in to get to to
help me pay the rent that month.
Pretty cool.
[inaudible]
once again,
thank you very much for this.
This was fantastic.
[inaudible] you,
thank you very much for this chat and let's give one more round.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.